I swear she's a well treated dog I guess
I was grateful you did not know now you
know your life is different now I look
this way I don't know if you can tell
but I'm doing some very strong Taylor
Swift Coachella 2016 purposeful cosplay
right now yeah Coachella the music
festival that has a purpose it's coming
up in the next couple weeks so I got
leading up to it
I would try and recreate some of your
favorite celebrity Coachella looks from
the past and went on Twitter and I asked
you guys just send me your favorite
looks and once you sent me sure let's
look from last year which is a very easy
way to start this off because it was
very easy
this is tongue-in-cheek but here's the
deal I'm going to actually try and
recreate these look as best I can with
the limited resources that I already
have on hand and I think what I call the
recruit great like recreation yeah it's
a stretch today I recreated the simple
and iconic Taylor Swift Coachella 2016
look and here's exactly how I did it
first I want to start with her gold
sneakers if you already have gold
sneakers cool for you you made a
purchase that you thought made you more
interesting than you actually are
but I'm going to DIY some old dirty
sneakers using yellow and gold fabric
paint I had lying around painters tape a
trash bag and my old dog stain converse
you're not better than me further into
is Hulk out this trash bag and rip the
sides to make it a bigger version of
itself to use as a tarp then we're going
to use what we have now come to realizes
duct tape to cover up the parts of the
sneaker that we do not want to spray
paint yellow gold they're going to
remove the sneakers laces and
spray-paint
the sneakers using the yellow fabric
paint we had lying around because at one
point in time we thought we might spray
in a rug that we weren't totally happy
with we purchased impulsively from Urban
Outfitters calm at a moment in time that
we weren't feeling the best about
ourselves but we're not the kind of
person to do that anyway you're not the
kind of person to wear those dumbass
gold sneakers you bought once you've let
our yellow fabric paint dry for a little
bit we're going to use this gold fabric
paints that we had lying around for I
honestly have no idea what reason to put
a topcoat on the yellow to make them
look more gold because it's gold and her
sneakers are gold and we're recreating
gold
let the sneakers completely dry before
we add the blue stars to them and move
on to telescope makeup in this look is
very Taylor Swift so let's go a very
Taylor Swift makeup look several
foundations return this bronze colors I
talked about some of their products in
my favorites video last month and this
is their brush foundation pump up oh you
just pump it up this is the Hans and
Franz of foundation you just pump it up
none of you know that he's white all
over your face oh my gosh oh did I break
here to pick it oh no there well this is
cool if you ever wanted your face to
feel like an accent wall on an HGTV home
makeover show treat yourself to this
foundation foundations on let's do under
I miss using this Maybelline age rewind
under-eye concealer and I'm just going
nuts great that looks like a face I
don't know but some of our eyebrow
precisely my brow pencil from benefit
look at it Wow filling in the brows this
look is very classic Taylor it's just
black eyeliner red lips clear skin clear
skin black island a red lips can't lose
but remember when you love Calvin Harris
at this Coachella
oh cool fine that's good enough now
let's do her eyes I can't tell what you
actually have on your eyelid maybe a
little black eyeliner maybe some subtle
color so let's do some neutral on both
on white under my brow bone and inner
corner tear duct and I take this light
pink color I'm great at showing makeup
and just s'matter it across my eyelid
that's been fine and good now I'm on the
black liner we're not doing away you
have tiny wing you join Kappa Red Bull
before you went out okay there is a
tiniest of wing mostly using bronze
colors Earvin line beauty stamp and
eyeliner it's a black liquid liner it
also has this star stamp the star stamp
on this kit so this liner is Coachella a
full oh I did too much of a wink it
looks like she's got black eyeliner
under her eyes let's put a little black
eyeliner under our eyes I'm going to use
Urban Decay perversion wow that's a
little bit ok can't myself because I'm
Jersey and I'm putting on okay we're
done stuff reshuffle weight is not
balanced yet oh my god my Jersey can't
stop it so great we're done now let's
mascara do they drive it back Wow no
good enough
a little blush and bronzer on I can't
even tell what's happening in the photo
if she has that rounder and now a little
bit of blush great now on to the main
thing she's got going is red lips today
I'm using Too Faced melted Mac liquid 5
matte long wear lipstick words words
words words words in the color lady
balls are you serious
y'all look perfect over it - faith I'm
not good I guess that's fine I got to
stop because I can't get it right and
it's stressing me out I'm touching it
too much I look like I just murdered a
small birds good enough makeup done
let's move on so this means it's time
for hair I don't have a bleached blond
of hair as Taylor Swift nor do I have
the bangs were the shortness in overall
life that she does but we're just going
to fake it because that's what good
Chelle is all about I didn't lose the
curled my hair earlier today I only do
much to it guys it's crazy side swept
bangs situation happening so it's like
this and then it sweeps itself that
looks so beautiful
I definitely don't look like a man
that's balding and desperately trying to
hide the fact that he's balding yeah
that kind of looked like it the hair is
pretty easy for me in this tutorial I
just touched it a bunch and then it
turned into something similar to
Taylor's let's move on to wardrobe I
don't have a black miniskirt like she
does but I have this black thing is this
actually I'm just going to wear this
underneath a oversized grey t-shirt
weirdos done now this is on to
accessories I don't have a silver star
necklace like the one Taylor has but I
do have a silver necklace chain and some
glittery silver paper and some scissors
and some hot glue and a false sense of
ability to DIY the necklace she's got on
at Coachella in this photo basically
we're just going to draw some star
shapes on this sticky glittery paper cut
them out and hot glue it into this
necklace it's a very simple process and
the results are very homemade look boo
now come back to our sneakers who have
dried overnight and this is what they
look like the morning after a lot better
than I look like the morning after heyo
so we're going to do is take this blue
glittery sticky paper that we had on
hand again don't know why and cut out
some star shapes then we're going to
take off the yellow duct tape to reveal
all of the white that's underneath and
we're going to hot glue the blue stars
on to the sides of the sneakers now it's
time to
the full look together we got our makeup
we got our necklace we got our great
t-shirt we're going to futz with their
hair a little bit and because calluses
hair is a little bit shorter we're going
to put it up in the back to give the
illusion of a shorter haircut never add
the final touches I use a silver pipe
cleaner to get the effect of this over
chain thing on her one ankle and then
she's got a black ankle bracelet on her
other ankle and I didn't have anything
so I decided to use a black pair of
panties and tethered around my ankle
which is twofold one it gives the
illusion of whatever the [ __ ] she has on
our ankle in the photo and two gives you
spare pair of panties at coachella which
is very very valuable currency and there
we go our look is almost complete the
very last thing you need is a very
disinterested looking friend that's
willing to stand in the shadows and hold
your hand while you seemingly have the
time of your life this baby not me gasps
okay that's it for this verses gentlemen
of recreation a celebrity Coachella
edition i me know in the comments your
favorite celebrity look some Coachella's
paths that i can recreate things like
this you don't give it a thumbs up and
click subscribe because I make videos
Monday Wednesday and Friday sometimes
and turn that little Bell notification
on so that you get notifications when I
make my videos because I mean and you're
going to want to know
I like assuming how you're going to feel
on that I don't know wait I forgot to do
the second photo here's the second one
[Music]